philippe laurent le maire de sceaux
monsieur laurent à bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous alors assaut il est donc
interdit de sortir sans avoir le nez et
la bouche cacher peu importe ce qui est
utilisé oui celle à partir de demain
sera donc en vigueur à partir de demain
en effet j'ai été amené à prendre cette
décision pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que j'ai reçu un certain nombre
d'avis d'experts médicaux comme
d'ailleurs tout le monde et notamment la
vie de l'académie de médecine qui est
une institution indépendante et qui n'a
subi de pression de personne et qui m'a
semblé donc tout à fait pertinente à
savoir qu' il vaut mieux se couvrir avec
quoi que ce soit plutôt que de ne rien
faire du tout pour bien chose et puis la
deuxième chose c'est que j'ai été tout
de même un peu surpris en réalité deux
du nombre de personnes qui étaient dans
la rue qui se promenaient parce que
c'est vraiment l'expression pendant tout
le week-end et que beaucoup de gens se
croisent et de manière très proche
certains qui s'était protégée la bouche
et nez et d'autres qui ne l'avait pas
fait et j'ai estimé qu'il était de santé
publique de célébrités public de faire
en sorte que tout le monde se protègent
la gauche est mené lorsqu'il est sur
l'espace public
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure une dame dans
le reportage dizaine de personnes ça
n'est pas vrai beaucoup de gens
rencontrent beaucoup de monde à sous
comme probablement ailleurs alors vous
venez de le dire pour motiver cette
décision vous est basée sur des avis
scientifiques
mais là aussi sont tous différents si
tout semble s'accorder sur la nécessité
du port d'un masque même artisanale les
médecins se contredisent sur
l'efficacité d'un foulard par exemple en
fleurs pas assez épais en tout cas oui
certainement c'est moins efficace le
foulard qu'un masque professionnels ça
va être soi mais c'est quand même
efficace et donc je ne vois pas en quoi
il faudrait dire qu'on ne doit pas le
faire alors même que ça représente une
certaine efficacité même si encore une
fois les limites et bien sûr moi je
crois que nous avons vraiment à
expliquer nos concitoyens qui doivent
être responsables pour eux-mêmes mais
qu'ils doivent aussi être responsable
pour les autres et en leur demandant de
faire ce geste qui est un geste assez
simple qui n'entrave en rien les
libertés publiques en leur demandant de
faire ce geste je leur demande
aussi d'être acteurs de la sécurité des
autres de protéger les autres à travers
à travers ce geste je pense que c'est
très important qu'il y ait en tout cas
cette prise de position un peu forte
malheureusement quand vous parlez de
recommandation personne ne vous écoute
les recommandations en france ça
n'existe pas c'est soit on essaye on
pose un acte fort comme l arrêté
municipal sont algériens vont en tout
cas le reste ne savent pas grand chose
et je regrette que l'état ne le fasse
pas lui-même d'ailleurs il pourrait le
faire sur l'ensemble du territoire
il aurait pu le faire depuis longtemps
en disant protégez-vous et protéger les
autres en portant quelque chose sur la
bouche et le nez lorsque vous êtes dans
l'espace public et on rappelle en selle
kaas hausse n'est pas une recommandation
mais c'est bien obligatoire de des
demandes de porter une protection alors
l'avis du gouvernement justement sur le
port du mas on a un peu de mal à à se
positionner à saisir cet avis on a quand
même l'impression qu'ils sont en train
de changer d'avis
radicalement on peut dire oui je te dis
ça en effet moi je comprends très bien
que le gouvernement n'ait pas obliger
tout le monde à porter un masque en tout
cas l'objet qui représente un masque des
débuts je n'avais pas assez et il était
naturel de les réserver naturellement
pour les soignants aujourd'hui à passer
non plus gros de la population d'élite
début le gouvernement aurait très bien
pu dire comme le virus se transmet
notamment par l'émission des postillons
lorsque vous parlez
eh bien il est nécessaire il est utile
même si c'est pas totalement efficace et
il est inutile donc de se protéger la
bouche et le nez ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on
gouvernement pouvait parfaitement faire
j'ai attendu qu'il le fasse il ne l'a
pas fait j'ai donc décidé de faire parce
que vous savez le maire il a aussi une
responsabilité générale en matière de
santé publique sur sa commune on l'a vu
avec que les arrêter sur le glyphosate
au printemps dernier ben là c'est un peu
de même nature lorsque nous estimons que
l'état ne va pas assez loin dans ses
mesures de protection générale de la
population bien les maires sont fondées
éventuellement à se substituer au moins
partiellement et ponctuellement à ce
qu'ils peuvent considérer comme une
insuffisance de l'état alors justement
vous avez rendu le port du masque
obligatoire à votre niveau pan de
l'apport de protelos protection
obligatoire à votre niveau
que pouvez-vous faire de plus et comptez
vous en faire plus bas à écouter et pour
l'instant ce que nous avons pu faire de
plus ensemble avec notamment la région
ile de france nous avons le faire aussi
avec l'association des maires de france
c'est d'essayer de se procurer
directement donc des masques là pour le
coup fabriquée pour cela des vaches au
pré donc d'un certain nombre de
fournisseurs on est lancés des commandes
groupées la région ile de france c'est
déjà arrivé en fin de semaine dernière
ses masques ont été destinés donc aux
professionnels de santé et aux
professionnels libéraux aux infirmières
aux médecins aux aides à domicile aux
pharmaciens aussi pour leur propre usage
également à tous les personnels qui
travaillent donc dans la sur le terrain
à la mairie par exemple les policiers
municipaux est d'ailleurs aussi l'épousé
nationaux j'en ai donné le sait la
police nationale voilà nous en avons
assez
pour ce type de personnel pendant
quelques jours ils ont 15 jours
mais évidemment de novembre nous n'avons
pas pour toute la population est donc
nous avons lancé avec les structures
importantes que sont pas jolis la bnf ou
de la région à nouveau
l'intercommunalité nous avons annoncé
toute une série de commandes op mais
nous ne savons pas quand nous serons
livrés malheureusement messieurs laurent
pardonner on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
est ce que vous avez appelé les autres
maires de france à faire comme vous je
ne les appelle pas spécialement les
autres maires me connaissent je suis
fait un général de l'association des
maires de france
évidemment je pense qu'ils ont peu ou
prou tous entendu ce que j'essaye de
faire assaut très modestement 1
je pense qu'un certain nombre d'entre
eux iront probablement dans le même sens
encore une fois il ne s'agit pas de
priver quoi que ce soit et qui que ce
soit une quelconque liberté
il s'agit simplement de leur dire
protégez vous si vous le faites pas pour
vous faites l'ont en tout cas pour les
autres c'est un mec vraiment de
responsabilité citoyenne que nous
demandons monsieur laurent merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire de sceaux dans les
hauts-de-seine où il est désormais
obligatoire dès demain de porter une
protection pour sortir de chez soi merci
merci